[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans six ans
par les sports vous êtes ici pendant une
heure aujourd'hui j'ai convoqué les
meilleurs autour de cette table pour
décrypter le sport local yvelinois ils
sont quatre ils sont motivés comme
jamais leur mission montrer qu'ils
méritent leur surnom la dream team à
présentation en musique
en commençant ma droite c'est le bruce
willis du cyclisme il n'a pas froid aux
yeux il adore les sensations fortes et
il aime se mettre dans des situations
périlleuses tout cela quand il enfourche
son vélo ou quand il met ses voleurs le
capitaine yann dujarrier du club de
vélizy 78 est avec nous m'ont michael
quand avez-vous très très bien vous êtes
le bruce willis du citoyen peut plus
chevelu quand même un peu vous au jdj
mai mais si nous on n'a pas peur on n'a
pas peur peut pâtir de la chute
on passe de l'autre côté un musique
c'est le sean connery de la bande
toujours habillée de façon élégante il
arrive toujours à s'en sortir tes larmes
james bond pour venir sur ce plateau
et aujourd'hui il a dû anticiper son
retour de la havane l'ancien président
des templiers georges agostino nous fait
l'honneur de venir dans cette émission
phare c'est le week-end merci beaucoup
en tout cas d'être demain - journal
voilà vous êtes venir un jet privé
j'arrive de l'avion le jeune coeur et la
tête de l'émission web un scénario
plateau je crois firme pour la suite on
repasse de l'autre côté musique c'est le
russell crowe de cette émission comme
cet acteur il adore endosser le costume
de gladiateurs pour partir au duel dans
cette émission
son objectif soulever les foules avec
des punchlines pierre chevallier qui
nous vient tout droit du rugby-club de
versailles nous fait encore l'honneur de
venir sur cette émission salut michael
forme et bonheur à tous
comment allez vous ça va super bien vous
avez révisé révisée sur les toits de la
main ni qu'elle chouchoute ac on est
très très sérieux vers s'ajoute à celle
le tient prudemment en termine à ma
droite musique c'est le george clooney
de cette émission quand il y a urgence
on peut toujours compter sur lui pour
nous sortir une analyse ville de cenon
what else la légende le
coach jean-louis ex-entraîneur de
plaisir nous fait l'immense honneur de
venir sur ce plateau une nouvelle fois
bonsoir michael bay soir à tous george
clooney mais après l'accident
cet instant 26 ans avant de passer au
programme de l'émission j'aimerais qu'on
revienne rapidement sur un événement à
la mi-novembre le cycliste philippe pons
et malades des poumons a réussi
l'exploit de boucler les deux le 200 m
lancé sur la piste en moins de 15
secondes pour réaliser cette performance
semblable un sprint à plus de 8000
mètres d'altitude
ce savoyard s'est entraîné à deux heures
par jour depuis juillet dernier avec son
record philippe pons et espère
sensibiliser le grand public sur sa
maladie des poumons le bepc au une
maladie qui touche environ 4 millions de
français que pensez vous de cet exploit
ja ne s'inquiète le cycliste de la bande
difficile de le mesurer puisque
puisqu'on n'est pas puisqu'on n'est pas
dans les mêmes conditions que ce que cet
homme
en termes de en termes de capacités
physiques donc voilà la seule chose que
l'on peut on peut souligner c'est que
quelle que soit la maladie
c'est la volonté qui fait que selon que
l'on peut surmonter les montagnes tout
simplement genre super avec soin très
bel exploit
certainement non je me suis peu à mesure
oui je dirai oui mais je rejoins ya dans
ce super mesure de dire si c'est un
exploit ou pas c'est surtout parce que
ils reviennent de loin qu'il arrive à
faire une telle performance sportive
mais après je suis pas un expert pour
savoir si si c'est vraiment une
performance je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas félicitations et bravo
si le corps est un outil qu'ils cassent
là c'est comme si le profond respect
quand quand c'est le mental qui prend le
qui prend le pas sur le sur le physique
réalisé une prestation de cette de cet
acabit là avec après une opération des
poumons et quelques et quand on quand on
pense à tout le contexte prêt au pays
post up a priori coup de chapeau
je le répète je voulais aussi nos
surtout qu'il a fait le don de 50 en
indiquant bien peu coquin une belle
rencontre
je me disais saint quentin en yvelines
sur la piste on a fait un tour de piste
pareil je suis pas un spécialiste le
pistard ses effets du mans mais bon donc
comme on dit douce après l'opération
surtout pour moi on en a besoin pour
n'importe où et n'importe quoi c'est
sûrement un espoir je sais pas c'est les
15 secondes
quel est le meilleur temps chez les
valides c'est une moins de moins de 10
secondes droite est donc voilà c'est ça
reste ça reste une performance qui est
anecdotique parce que là qu'un second
sur 1 200 je trouve pas que ce soit ce
soit parlant maintenant et je trouve
presque dommage que l'on compte les deux
peut-être limité à faire 200 m il a
peut-être fallu reconnaître s'ils
pouvaient pas faire je connais pas les
conditions je connais pas assez la
personne mais voilà je pense que d'un
200 m 1 200 m c'est un effort qui est
très violent on peut vraiment se mettre
vraiment appeler presse non mais presque
presque c'est vrai que comme moi non non
ça n'est pas relancé
et c'est vrai que quand quand on quand
on se lance dans la pente je pense que
sur le 200 m moi je mets jamais moins de
noces ou moins de 11 secondes
je dois respirer trois fois peut-être
c'est vraiment très très très très court
donc sur 1 sur 1 sur 1 pour une personne
comme ça je pense que oui peut-être pu
faire faire un une poursuite sur sur 3
km aurait peut-être été un peu plus un
peu plus parlant parce que là c'est
quand même une discipline qui est très
très spécifiques et et du coup je trouve
que chronométriquement parlant c'est pas
c'est pas assez
c'est alors que leur a peut-être
d'autres encore je lui souhaite de et en
plus des dix lignes sont beaucoup plus
accessibles comme la poursuite jeudi
voilà sur trois kilomètres ça doit
correspondre à cette catégorie d'âge ben
je pense que là on pourrait vraiment
beaucoup plus mesuré 2
l'exploit parce que pascal il sait avoir
réalisé cette affaire voilà mais dans
quel but
dans quel but sensibiliser sans
séditieuse et par rapport à sa maladie
par rapport à la décennie pour ça que je
rejoigne je comprends le challenge est
réussi et en studio tout à fait tout à
fait nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler football et plus
particulièrement de mercato charles
itandje ans un gardien international du
cameroun et de lens a rejoint le club de
versailles
focus à suivre nous ferons également un
coup de projecteur sur le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
qui affiche des résultats décevant mais
avant de développer ces thèmes
on va parler de thèmes ligne on commence
donc par du dôme ligne de la gymnastique
acrobatique le club des clayes-sous-bois
abrite un champion du monde
axel duriez 13 ans a décroché
mi-novembre la médaille d'or dans la
catégorie des 13-14 ans à saint
pétersbourg en russie
une première pour ce jeune champion nous
avons reçu axel duriez et son coach rené
et ben ami sur le note sur notre
émission de 7,8 sport on regarde cette
séquence pas encore encore mais je
commence à redescendre petit à petit a
commencé à y croire
vous réalisez pas encore totalement
totalement mais petit à petit ça
commence à se réaliser
je sais dire dans ma tête tu es champion
du monde
vous réalisez vous aussi pour axel sinon
ils pourront également qui s'est
vraiment récent c'est pendant ces trois
semaines de l'an 3 semaines en est en
effet sur un petit nuage et je pense
cacau deux jours que je réalise que
vraiment c'est fait que ce n'est pas un
rêve et que on est vraiment champion du
monde
axel duriez a également été reçu en
mairie par le maire des clayes-sous-bois
ce samedi 1er décembre il a reçu à cette
occasion une distinction de la villa
questions sur ce thème
est ce que cette performance peut mettre
en lumière ce sport oui non ou était non
non non oui on fait un petit duel entre
vous y allez jean yanne vous commencez
oui alors moi je dis oui puisque
c'est oui c'est un sport mineur on est
d'accord maintenant en local bien sûr
que ça va mettre en lumière en plus
c'est un
un garçon qui a 13 ans donc ça va savoir
au niveau du collège et ça m'a donné
l'envi à des personnes qui le
connaissent de au moins d'essayer cette
discipline après tout le monde ne
performera pas il doit certainement
avoir les qualités exceptionnelles pour
pouvoir être champion du monde à cet âge
il faisant donc donc c'est génial mais
maintenant ou bien sûr qu'un champion du
monde à cet âge va permettre de pouvoir
parler de la discipline en tout en
restant en local bien sûr on est bien
d'accord et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on en parle aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs etc des raisons pratiques jeu
mais vers genre ce qui vous a convaincu
où vous restez sur votre nom non
malheureusement et je dis bien
malheureusement parce que l'on parle pas
de la performance sportive parce que la
performance sportive est énorme un titre
championne du monde quelque discipline
que ce soit c'est une grande performance
sportive mais malheureusement il y en a
souligné juste trop peu d'ailleurs c'est
malheureusement une discipline mineure
et on voit même déjà ne serait-ce que
toute la gymnastique avec tout ce qui
peut se passer à la gymnastique et ça
fait pas lever les foules et ça attire
pas grand monde
donc malheureusement malheureusement je
ne pense pas que ça va ça va ça va créer
des
d'émulation des émulations sûr que le
nombre de licenciés sur ce club dans mes
chaussures le club parce que proches
comme ça mais j'ai honte qu'un
malheureux doyen locale parce que
malheureusement il ya trois semaines la
chance et en gymnastique en france et
9000 dans la gymnastique acrobatique
dont le tumbling
c'est à dire oui quelques milliers de
personnes oui mais même là où on voit on
voit langage que procure la gymnastique
en règle générale j'ai encore une fois
ça c'est pas lever les foules de quoi
mise à part les cas les aficionados tu
vois là donc c'est tout
malheureusement je dis bien
malheureusement il a raison et il yal
aussi dire que c'est une discipline
mineure
ça me fait penser à un autre un autre
sportif qui est 25 fois champion ronaldo
véliplanchiste fin de cinq fois champion
du monde de sa discipline
la pole la planche à voile c'est
sûrement un tout petit peu plus
médiatique que le tumbling mais est
encore donc à la question précise
est ce que un titre de champion du monde
peut mettre en avant mettre en avant un
sport on a la réponse avec la planche à
voile fin de cinq titres le goes il est
il est pas plus il fait pas plus
connaître sa discipline à chaque fois
qu'il a un titre de plus on en parle un
tout petit peu et puis après le soufflé
retombe on a quand même on a quand même
un français le plus titré dans une
discipline et son sport et pas est
patraque titre
à 13 ans jean jacques boissinot s'est
trop confidentielle comme spa moi je
dirais on enlève la dizaine de sports
faute rugby vélo etc
pendant les dix après tout le reste
confidentiel on arrive à un moment donné
à partir de la douzième place
même les américains malheureusement y
compris le football américain
on en parle aux jeux olympiques le tir
le tir à l'arc ping-pong tout ça mais on
entre on est dans cette même logique si
ce qui a mal à il obtient une médaille
olympique si ce sport devient olympiques
on va en parler pendant quinze jours
très bien il va être assurée le jeudi
soir justement été olympiques en 1932 et
olympique à los angeles mais depuis il
ne figure plus au jeu c'est dommage
parce que c'est très spectaculaire j'ai
vu des matches est très spectaculaire
après malheureusement des hommes jeudi à
part les 7-8 mai sport majeur en france
et dans le monde j'y reste on retrouve
le même sport un peu partout yann il
faut que ça soit olympique forcément non
enfin même si c'était olympiques ça
donnerait pas plus de visibilité je vais
dans deux camps mais les frères guenot
qui avait d'ailleurs sonne qui regarde
ça reste ça reste ça reste sur une
période de 15 jours j'imagine la piste
et donc du coup on en a d'autres pistes
sont les jeux olympiques c'est mort et
bien sûr ces morts là elle est ainsi qu
il nous narre dans 15 jours parce qu'il
ya la suisse il ya des évidences urs et
c'est par là et le dis ça je suis un
fort 4 par exemple même si à populariser
sa discipline attention martin fourcade
sur le biathlon c'est quand même quelque
chose encore différent il y avait
raphaël poirée avant il y avait déjà des
gens qui connaissaient le qui connaissez
le
le biathlon on a déjà eu des champions
avant d'un martin fourcade je dirai
juste qu'il a le le capital sympathie et
l'acsel thuriès pourrez la voir
également ce qu'elle est allée bien sûr
mais oui mais ça ne suffit d'aller
encore elle est encore plus
plus anecdotique que le club ait atteint
sa sonde efficace une culture du sport
aussi tu pas d'en parler de biathlon là
il ya plus une culture ancrée en france
sur la pratique du biathlon avec des
générations de skieurs qui soit deux
tiers de fond de nous des skieurs de
piste là sur le 2 mai sur l'automie nice
est quand même relativement récent il ya
peu d'arriérés
après ça ça mais quand même un gros coup
de projecteur ponctuelles le tout béton
est temps que ce soit pas un feu de
paille sur cette discipline la de la
halle à développer et à faire exploser
le nom de 10 ans il ya sûrement mais
sûrement pas on en parle un petit peu
désormais il ya il ya une place à se
faire parmi beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de sport ou d'un autre côté à choisir il
vaut mieux avoir le communiqué avec un
titre de champion du monde que rien du
tout pour l'été se boit ou penser qu'il
va y avoir un impact sérieux et très
local on veut et très local est très
ponctuel sûrement sans doute après ça va
être aussi la belle la manière dont dont
ce jeune champion va avoir à en parler
en plus de la partie de la partie
médiane c'est vrai qu'on en parle
aujourd'hui donc il ya une petite île
est une petite porte qui s'ouvre sur ce
sur ce sport là et localement pour les
clés il a sa photo notamment sur le
gymnase de ces c'est en train de répéter
fait péter les licenciements après sais
pas si ça sera reconduit c'est à dire
que s'il devient sherbrooke il redevient
champion du monde l'année prochaine puis
les années suivantes aussi bas ça peut
être ça peut être intéressant et ensuite
il faut aussi qu'ils aient d'autres
champions dans du monde dans d'autres
clubs
et là on va on va commencer peut-être en
parler un peu plus tu sais c'est
difficile pour ces petits sports quoi
après le tumbling nous allons parler
football un match à ne pas manquer si
vous êtes un amateur de la coupe de
france le dernier représentant évinois
aversa et qui évolue en nationale iii
reçoit ce samedi à 8 décembre le
mythique rc lens dans son stade moreau
8e tour de la compétition
un rendez vous que va manquer charles
itandje anciens joueurs de lancer
aujourd'hui gardien de but de versailles
il est blessé
aujourd'hui il est âgé de 36 ans il a
rejoint le club l'été dernier et c'est
un gros plus pour l'entraîneur de
versailles on écoute du coup sûr
l'entraîneur
chile charlie temps c'est un
professionnel un professionnel à une
belle carrière une belle carte de visite
dès que le prestigieux à
coupe du monde donc c'est ça reste ça
reste quelqu'un dans le monde du
football et c'est vraiment une chance de
l'avoir parmi nous au quotidien ce qu'il
apporte par ses qualités de joueur de
footballeur mais aussi par ses qualités
humaines
donc c'est un exemple à suivre pour tous
nos joueurs ils sont un vrai plus
charlie tange est passé par lens où il a
évolué pendant six saisons il a joué
comme gardien remplaçant liverpool
pendant quatre ans avant de rejoindre la
grèce et notamment le pas oxelo nique et
puis à direction la turquie avec un
passage à konyaspor l'a également à
participer à des matches de coupe du
monde comme on peut le voir sur ces
images une carrière très riche
la question sur ce thème est ce que
c'est une surprise de la voir à
versailles de le voir arriver à verser
oui oui on fait un petit duel entre
georges agostinho oui c'est peut-être la
première édition avait encore du mal
bouffe et georges agostino vous qui êtes
un passionné de football de l'héritage
oui sur physique me dit quelque chose
les faits c'est effectivement je connais
pas il sait pas votre club de coeur et
non est-ce qu'ils avaient un lien avec
leur versailles déjà non il est
originaire de la région parisienne
il a joué aux lilas au red star dans sa
jeunesse voie d'accord parties à alençon
ben c'est un gros coup de projecteur est
sûrement sur le terrain il apporte parce
que le gardien de 36 ans on voit bien
autres gilles nationale afin de se lier
on voit bien qu'à 40 ans voire plus ils
sont toujours là donc c'est un véritable
plus pour versailles ça c'est évident
alors qu'est ce qu'il vient faire à
versailles à 36 ans puisque sa carrière
encore loin d'être là on a essayé de
poser la question et n'a pas voulu
répondre pour l'instant voilà une
chambre château je sais pas ça laisse le
temps
d'accord il a tout enfin il faut que le
club en profite ça peut pas durer des
années et des années aussi bien
médiatiquement parce qu'un gars qui a
fait la coupe du monde qui a joué dans
la liberté les autres et un coup de
projecteur a donné même si versailles et
sont déjà serrano mai mais il faut
qu'ils en profitent tous effectivement
l'espérance de ce gala on l'a vu sur les
images il est avec modric le ballon d'or
notamment 2014
modric ballon d'or aujourd'hui
est à versailles au départ un petit
retard dès maintenant c'est passé très
vite
c'est pas du tout le fait pas du tout le
sujet non va super et moi je pense
surtout qu'il va apporter énormément en
expérience aux joueurs lors des séances
d'entraînement lors d avant match pour
donner des conseils pour eux de dire au
but alors et non mais alors là par
contre grosse confiance c'est à dire que
moi je joue enfin je préfèrerais l'avoir
dans mon équipe que dans l'équipe
adverse
parce que en effet il va y avoir un
poids psychologique sur les adversaires
en dix ans on a un gardien de ligue 1 en
face moi je me souviens de faim mais pas
très 2b d'ailleurs je crois qu'il joue
il joue encore un ancien joueur de
monaco qui joue maintenant
cfa 2 je crois qu'ils aient à esbly du
sud merci d'aiguilhe qui joue avec il
joue aujourd'hui pour le plaisir
et voilà et c'est vrai que son aura fait
que ça se démultiplient surtout les sur
tous les autres joueurs et ils ont même
pas besoin d'être sur le terrain parfois
juste que des lettres sur le banc de
touche
je vais parler de cristiano ronaldo lors
d'une finale où il a été il s'était
blessé contre la france ben voilà il
avait beau être sur le banc de touche
il a il était toujours présent sur le
sur le terrain pour pour ces pour ses
équipiers et donc là que l'euro est
mauvais souvenir et donc donc là moi je
je je pense que pour versailles et pour
les joueurs de versailles c'est un très
très gros plus très gros plus et
j'espère que ça va durer longtemps sur
la question surprise ou pas surpris je
suis partagé entre deux points le
premier on en parle souvent ici c'est
que les carrières de dans certains
sports sont assez courtes
la gardien de but c'est un petit peu
différent mais une retraite une retraite
active pour faire profiter les joueurs
de son expérience là c'est pas une
surprise de le retrouver à plus faible
niveau
l'autre point qui me tarabuste un peu
c'est effectivement une surprise puisque
puisque versailles versa il n'est pas
forcément ni au niveau sportif et
médiatique des autres clubs qu'il a pu
il a pu fréquenter
à côté de ça maintenant je pense que
c'est une chance que doit prendre la
ville de versailles et l'équipe de foot
de versailles comme elle vient c'est à
dire vraiment comme une source
d'expérience on parlait de séance de
tirs au but je pense que là dans le
sport amateur on en parle souvent ici ça
se termine dans le foot amateur ça se
termine souvent aux tirs au but
là une expérience comme celle de charles
itandje à la fois pour ses coéquipiers
pour tirer des tirs au but et puis lui
quand il occupe la cage et
pour les arrêter et pour pour mettre la
pression sur les tireurs adverses
ça c'est du bonus donc je pense qu'on
peut en parler encore un petit peu
souvent ici si jamais il est amené à
rester quelques saisons plus ce genre
vous a pas entendu sur sur la question
je pense que mes confrères fait on fait
le tour moi je rajouterais juste
simplement parce qu'être à 10 ans pour
un gardien de but c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas vieux
on voit enfin c'est quand même une fin
de carrière qu il entend voir une jeune
homme qui est arrivé au psg qui à plus
40 ans 41 je crois qu'il a un qui est un
cas exceptionnel
c'est un cas exceptionnel certes mais
non fabien barthez a été a été longtemps
voilà je pense que c'est le corps
célestes et messieurs je ne sais pas et
je pense que c'est un peu pour ça ou on
peut durer un peu plus que ce que sur le
chat moi je pense quand même surtout
c'est qu'il a pas eu d'autres
propositions plus intéressantes pour ça
que c'est un petit peu un choix par
défaut
mais honnêtement sportivement je vois je
vois pas pire l'a dit je vous vois pas
ce que le faire à versailles a passé une
équipe qui versailles
je suis amené à jouer les premiers rôles
en nationale 2 dans les années à venir
effet national de même centre entre le
haut de tableau du football français et
international puisse quitter liverpool
et
la sonal 3 à versailles c'est un gouffre
qui lasse il a assuré ses arrières
financiers
pour lui si les berjalliens versa et
donc se dire ben moi j'ai plus envie de
m'emmerder tout simplement armé mais je
pense qu'il a pas voulu
ce ne serait ce qu il n'a pas non plus
d'autres propositions et inquiété d'un
projet sympa était de projet sympa et
que les gens passent aime pas non mais
moi c'est pas d'un joueur de haut niveau
tu pars pas alors que tu es
professionnel à haut niveau tu vas pas
dans un club
excusez moi pour le projet sepa bhl
sinon pour être sur le banc
non je pense que il est pour ca
peut-être qui dit qui prend du temps
pour réfléchir
lorsqu'on lui pose la réponse proposée
pose la question de pardon parce qu'il
attend aussi avoir des ouvertures et
autre chose à proposer et à dire aux
journalistes quoi mais vous ne voyez pas
nombreuses saisons à versailles ou juste
cette année moi j'aurais tendance à dire
on le verra jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient levé
notre proposition plus intéressante
bon je sais je ne connais pas le budget
du foot à versailles
après je pense je pense qu'il a fallu il
a fallu quand même lui proposer quelque
chose de décent par rapport à son
pedigree et son cv mais encore une fois
ça tu aux ados ils visitent jadot katif
c'est une vraie chance et et pour la
ville de versailles et le hasard faisant
que malheureusement il peut pas jouer
bas depuis mai il peut il peut
c'est lens qui se présentent à
versailles ça fait une très belle
affiche et peut-être que là uniquement
grâce à lui c'est grâce au rc lens mais
on peut avoir une belle affluence au
stade mimoun justement on va terminer là
dessus un petit pronostic autour de
cette table pour ce match vous commencez
genre agostino passionné de foot jeux
que vous êtes vous devez avoir
alors malheureusement l'on sait devoir
donc ça va faire du 3 3 1 pour lens
ouais même si dans ce mail est enfin
celui ci comme dans ces tombes de lens
était compliquée oui bien sûr mais il ya
quand même à creuser car trois ans
sortir les vidéos après genre 2-0 pour
l'ase alger le footballeur versailles
non mais c'est face ce serait magnifique
mais ça va être difficile il faut
surtout revu faut surtout pas de salut
aux tirs au but
il leur manque charlie orange maintenant
les ballons direction le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines notre focus du
jour ça va mal pour le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
rapport d'activité de vélo police
exploitant du vélodrome nationale sur
l'année 2017 a été dévoilé
la structure a accueilli seulement 35
mille personnes sur des activités à
titre commercial comme des séminaires
des baptêmes sur piste ou encore des
projets événementiels des activités
liées à la présence des équipes de
france de cyclisme ont quant à elles
généré 6060 visiteurs pas suffisant pour
être bénéficiaire la structure affiche
un résultat d'exploitation en déficit de
six cent cinquante trois mille euros
on écoute le président de 50 ans les
mines jean michel flos bien sûr qu'il
faut donner il faut nous demander plus
c'est pour ça qu'on a changé d'ayant
l'opérateur puisqu'on prend l'ucp amène
à partir du 1er janvier
18 bien sûr que c'est un c'est un
opérateur beaucoup plus actif dans les
événements sportifs dans l'est dans le
réseau
donc voilà on a pris quelqu'un qui est
comme une notoriété plus forte que donc
de tout autre opérateur pour augmenter
la rentabilité
bien sûr de ce vélodrome comme on l'a
entendu dans l'interview pour booster la
fréquentation du site l'ucp à l'union
nationale des centres sportifs de plein
air qui gère déjà des piscines des
centres et cassé des patinoires va
remplacer vélopolis voilà vous
connaissez tous le cpa mois ce qui avec
le cda
vous connaissez j'ai peur ils gèrent la
fosse de plongée sous-marine à 10,9 la
gare et opposition je pensais pas en
danger ils sont pas du tout dans
l'événementiel ils sont pas du tout là
pour remplir 7,8
c'est la question c'est l'avis de la
série uniquement des missionnaires de la
gestion aquatique ou autre mais ces 17
et gestionnaire il ressort des familles
très bien on est à la montagne à la
plage et tout mais bon c'est pas du tout
vo plus si c'était compliqué j'essaie de
travailler avec eux et c'était très
compliqué demander beaucoup d'argent
pour la location du les romains il faut
le remplir toute façon vu qui est
déficitaire
nous on avait un projet sont revient
juste une petite parenthèse on veut
c'est jouer on faisait jouer un match de
quarts des américains contre une
sélection d'elancourt et on avait sexion
d'assaut derrière le groupe ses
actionnaires soit au top c'est quelque
chose même si les gens venaient pour
nous pour nous ça nous faisait de la pub
on le propulser le truc et c'était quand
même vingt mille euros par jour sur deux
jours comme on a dit qu'on n'a pas les
moyens il nous prenait la tête à tête
des recettes donc elles sont appliquées
c'est compliqué oui mais il faut les
vêtements il faut se serait peut-être
mieux avec le cpa peut-être non mais
c'est aujourd'hui je le problème de
l'oeuf alors là le gros problème c'est
bien sympa d'avoir mis du cpa mais il
n'apporte aucune différence sur la
structure qui était existantes avec vélo
police c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui quand
vous voulez rentrer en contact avec lui
cpa vous retrouvez vous rencontrerez les
mêmes personnes que celles que vous avez
vu avant las il ya une seule nouvelle
personne c'est le directeur qui a changé
donc maintenant c'est une personne qui
est du cpr mais il leur est l'équipe qui
en place et l'équipe qui était
existantes avant nous en termes
d'abonnés pour pouvoir accéder au
vélodrome ont commencé à rencontrer des
problèmes pour pour avoir des coaches
sur les sur les créneaux je pensais que
le cpa avec ses ressources humaines
arriverait à faire former des des
personnes qui ont déjà des brevets et
qui aurait juste eu besoin d'avoir un
peu plus d'expérience sur la piste et
bien même ça ils ne sont pas capables
aujourd'hui les solutions pour les
créneaux ont été trouvés mais ont été
résolus par une ancienne équipe qui
était déjà en place avant donc pour moi
aujourd'hui lui cpa n'apporte rien du
tout je ne je ne sais pas ce qu'ils sont
venus faire ici j'ai eu une réunion il
ya de la cen-sad a jugé au monde j'ai eu
une réunion ces réunions après la
rentrée
après la rentrée avec le avec le nouveau
directeur eh ben j'ai été assez surpris
par les réponses qu'ils pouvaient nous
apporter parce qu'en effet il y avait un
prénom qui a pas de projet et et puis
vous êtes d'arrivée peut-être alors là
c'est du temps ouais bien sûr mais le
problème c'est que le vélodrome ça fait
maintenant quatre cinq ans qu'il est
qu'il existe mois-ci ancien quatrième
directeur en sur le quatrième directeur
et est ce lui le dernier qui a été
quittée en place à une jarre aux usa roa
à la seule façon qu'il a eue de
d'assainir les comptes c'est de réduire
la masse salariale de deux vélos police
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui avec la structure ils ont
rajouté une un millefeuille haut
dans l'organigramme ça me paraît très
très très très compliqué et je vois mal
je vois mal comment je vois mal le jeu
voit l'avenir très très naïve assad
la question c'est est ce qu'on parle de
risque on parle d' attirer des
spectateurs pour le cyclisme ou des
spectateurs en général on en a souvent
parlé sur ce plateau
il ya eu plein de plein d'événements
comme il y avait de la moto cross s'il y
avait eu des matchs de handball féminin
et qui avait plutôt à priori plutôt bien
marché et attirer un petit peu les
foules pour les matches d'ici paris qui
est maintenant devenu le pari 92 il y
avait environ entre 4000 et 5000
personnes
c'est donc c'est donc c'est dans la
moyenne là c'était un total que vous
donniez au départ à sur les civils le
total c'est exactement trente cinq mille
personnes sur une année l'année 2010 est
en termes des séminaires des événements
commerciaux comme par exemple voilà
l'aller on voit à l'écran le championnat
de judo tout ça ne rentre pas en ligne
de compte pour pour lever le don de 50
ans no mi dance qui est activités
cyclistes seulement par contre il y à
6060 visiteurs pour les activités c'est
la capacité à développer ce chiffre là
qui est qui et sur l'essence même du
dieu du vélodrome du cpa est un est un
spécialiste de gestion de sang
multisports dont beaucoup de temps
beaucoup de soin votre beaucoup
d'activités ils vont peut-être pouvoir
rapport à porter des pratiquants se
pratiquant sur des stages sur des sur
des opérations particulières sur en plus
de l'activité professionnelle après le
reste apporté les cités des spectateurs
c'est un c'est un projet de beaucoup
plus
il ya quand même quelques activités
danse entre pistes notamment du
badminton faut rajouter la boxe à une
époque la boxe trois mille personnes est
normalement monde sur la boxe il faut
suivre sur le monde ils ont ils ont au
tout début il avait d'emblée fait 15
novembre de l'année dernière une norme
le mans d'habitations non non non moi je
papote de l'activité sera pas
d'événement box où je parle du
activité boxe à dire qu'il y avait un
club de boxe qui venaient faire un
entraînement sur le centre c'était pas
du tout dérangeant c'était est en effet
il était relativement nombreux la tour
mesurera pour que deux gars s'entraînent
ce soit sur sur un ring mais je problème
il est général on voit bien le stade de
france gerland tout ça à marseille il
mise tout sur lisent pas que sur le foot
et pourtant le foot ça attire mais pour
que ce soit viable leur projet soit
viable
ils sont des événements des chanteurs
des il faut il faut il faut ouvrir ce
toute l'année
enfin à part un tweet de hip-hop ou je
ne sais plus quoi que c'est ça un
événement de la cuve aux intéristes
techno qui a ramené c'est la plus belle
affiche finalement pour pour le
vélodrome ça a attiré 5000 personnes
plus de 5000 personnes même vous nous
mettez les îles hébrides mère du groupe
de jeunes chez sûr que qui le remplit
allègrement deux trois quatre cinq fois
par an la question sur ce thème faut-il
être inquiet pour le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
oui ou non pour le devenir ou non tous
avaient le partager non moi je dis non
non simplement pour une seule et bonne
raison c'est que ben paris à lille jeux
olympiques en 2024 donc de toutes façons
jusque là il y aura d'exploitation est
en effet par contre ce sera le
contribuable qui paiera
et puis et puis c'est tout il ya eu ce
sont tout a été foutu en dépit du bon
sens c'est une c'est une catastrophe
le juste le site internet pour pouvoir
faire les réservations il ya trois
prestataires pour s'occuper du site
internet vous sont incapables de pouvoir
faire une modification
maintenant qu'ils appuieront c'est trop
compliqué pour pouvoir le refaire enfin
voilà tout et moi j'ai des réunions tous
les deux fois par enfin plusieurs fois
par an avec eux et c'est très très
compliqué tout est toujours trop
compliqué vous pensez qu'un jour
peut-être le verdon pourrait fermer 50
alors bien sûr non il ya quand même
quelques quelques
point d'espoir comme comme paris 2024
notamment sur la sur la zone après la
concurrence est rude
que ce soit dans le sport ou dans les
salles de spectacle avec multi activités
on voit on voit avec notamment
l'avènement de de paris la défense arena
récemment qui a mis dont ils ont pris le
problème
la problématique al'inverse c'est au
départ pour accueillir des sportifs et
et maintenant on fait beaucoup beaucoup
de spectacle la la la derrière c'est
pour le pour le vélodrome c'est s'est
diversifiée au maximum également
l'activité il faut remplir il faut
ouvrir parce qu'on ne voudrait pas que
par l'activité cycliste ont fermé non en
revanche ils vont avoir des années d
année compliquée oui ça va être ça avait
des fréquentations un petit peu en berne
on le voit dans toutes les enceintes
sportives comme le dit comme l'a rappelé
george c c'est sûr c'est on a du mal à
faire recette sur quel que soit le sport
majeur où il ya le mot de la fin pour
pour vous georges excusez moi je me
trompe ou il ya c'est le sol vélodrome
en france ah non les couverts couvert
ouvert pour dire celui d'hier il ya
celui à bordeaux aujourd'hui à bordeaux
et bordeaux c'est pareil c'est pas du
tout exploité roubaix enfin pas du tout
ce côté en dehors de l'activité semble
avait décidé nommé couvert roubaix
roubaix aussi regarder encore ouvert
mais pas de cette taille par contre il y
en a un autre apport de voix après ce ne
sont pas des autres le sens critique en
place devançant problématique qui vient
c'est que ce vélodrome
il est pas surdimensionner puisque c'est
très bien d'avoir cinq mille 5000 places
assises du coup on intègre une structure
qui correspond au même
vos de sécurité que le stade de france
et donc du coup quand vous déplacer au
vélodrome
eh bien il faut le même le même bar d'à
de sécurité que pour aller au stade de
france
et c'est pas du tout enfin voilà et là
c'est démesuré et du coup les coûts sont
trop élevés a posé sa marque un parti
nocifs ça sera moins la fin il manque
des parkings en ville de saint quentin
en yvelines
je vous propose maintenant de prendre
une grande bouffée d'oxygène et de vous
équiper de votre masque et de votre tube
à nous allons parler apnée dans cette
émission xavier delpy licencié à
versailles ancien habitant d'elancourt
est médecin à l'hôpital de trappes a
réalisé en egypte il ya quelques
semaines une plongée en apnée en poids
constant de 101 m et une autre de 111
mètres en poids variable record
personnel pour lequel il s'est
énormément entraîné en l'écoutent
ça fait cinq ans pour moi que j'y pense
que je m'entraîne pour avec des éléments
des clés à chaque fois qu'ils peuvent
manquer il ya énormément de préparation
physique dans l'année c'est peut être
deux entraînements de crossfit par
semaine en régime d'entraînement
régulier de séance d'entraînement en
natation en nage avec palmes que mon
coach en desrochers qui verront si ma
préparation physique c'est de l'hypnose
avec mon hypnothérapeute pascal
jacquinot cosson pour préparer le mental
tout ce qui va arriver
est-ce qu'on veut mettre en place et
puis des entraînements en apnée pure ça
genre une réaction même pas non c'est
sûr que c'est bien ça c'est bien on a
tous toujours on parle toujours du drame
à l'heure du grand bleu
non mais c'est vrai toujours pas
d'amener
laminé tout le monde par de l'eau du
grand bleu mais c'est vrai que ça et
c'est assez phénoménal mais j'avais lu
vu une chose qui est un gars qui avait
dit apprendre à ne pas respirer c'est
d'abord apprendre à respirer
voilà y'a déjà y est vous le connaissez
et xavier le passé un copain c'est là
qu'on pense que dire du match ordinaire
en pas du tout on se connaît depuis
depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années
on faisait du roller ensemble il ya
quelques années sur les sur les coupes
de france
il n'est pas si évident non plus voilà
non on se téléphone très régulièrement
se voit aussi assez régulièrement et en
effet c'est il invite à venir faire un
petit tour pour pour un petit peu
découvrir découvrir ce milieu et qui
permet aussi d'en connaître plus sur soi
donc donc en effet c'est quelque chose
que j'ai serré un moment mais voilà
alors je suis super content pour lui
c'est parce que ça fait plusieurs ça
fait longtemps qu'ils en parlent de de
cela et il a vraiment axé sa préparation
de là dessus puisque aujourd'hui il faut
pas oublier xavier a été médaillé de
bronze aux jeux aux championnats du
monde donc il est connu dans le connu
dans le milieu et faut pas oublier que
voilà qu'après les plus sûres de l'apnée
plutôt avec des records personnels
les voitures d'aujourd'hui au voilà
aujourd'hui il fait moins de compétition
et ils prévention voilà c'est pour lui
voilà et de fait pour lui et donc du
coup voilà ça c'était c'était une
barrière qui voulaient aller chercher et
je pense que les les spécialistes de ce
type d'effort peuvent peuvent
véritablement bien mesurer ce qu'il a à
ce qu'il a réalisé et ça doit être un
cercle restreint restreint de pouvoir
passer les mesures que la barre des 100
m manière des monopoles à lui descendu
descendu a point d'autre voilà d'autres
d'autres d'autre part la force la force
centrifuge ça les rebelles seraient folk
est impacté son sa vie et sa
personnalité parce que ça a l'air d'être
quelqu'un de extrêmement zen poser roule
c'est pour ça qu'on en fait très bien
avec une avec une respiration
jusqu'il et andré contrôler saga
vraiment de marquer sa personnalité d'un
point de vue fort la question sur ce
thème la planète il un sport accessible
à tous quand on voit le travail de sa
demande est ce que c'est un sport
accessible à tous non entre vous je
règle hoste hinault et pierre chevalier
d'or je pensais que ça je dirais cadeau
non non parce que déjà on a vu qu'en
france il ya qu une seule un seul
endroit où ils peuvent réellement
s'entraîner après le commun des mortels
et ben on n'habite pas dans des endroits
où il ya des fausses même en france je
sais pas si le côté monaco je crois
qu'il ya des endroits où ils peuvent on
ferme c'est pas un sport à part faire
appeler dans la piscine dans sa
baignoire
c'est un sport pas très accessible et
puis c'est un sport physique faut tout
toute une atmosphère autour du sport le
zen attitude zen attitude
une manière d'être gagnant de vie voit
sûrement moi je reste toujours dans ce
grand bleu qui nous a amenés mais c'est
tout un c'est très très particulier
comme sport et donc à partir de là c'est
pas un sport ouvert à tout
d'ailleurs je connais pas le nombre de
puits par en egypte notamment à pour
plonger ont déjà les moyens d'aller
l'egypte où aller pour l'éponger donc je
ne vois pas ce sport évoluer ça reste
très confidentielle avec des personnes
très en avant très spécifique bien c'est
simplement une façon de l'accessibilité
à tous
moi j'ai une amie qui ne perturbe pas
duel pour l'instant il ya des alliés
habituels et si je vois pas le si c'est
suffisant aux âmes à moi ce soir est
restée un quart d'heure ah si je veux
bien mais tel qu'on voit les films
hollywoodiens ils descendent 20 30 40
100 m c'est compliqué ça vienne 200 m la
question des archives alger c'est de
savoir à partir de quand on nous parle
réellement de pratique de l'apnée
tu l'as dit on
on l'a tous pratiqué soit dans une
baignoire dans une piscine au bord de la
mer on a touché les concours de retenir
sa respiration deux fois depuis deux ans
de force ou comme dans le draft et rixes
avec soupe à l'oignon micro tome qui
retient sa respiration là on l'a tous
fait petit on est autour de cette table
je pense tous marqués par le par le
grand bleu et part et par le message
qu'il véhicule et je pense qu'il n'y a
pas besoin de réelles capacités
physiques pour retenir sa respiration au
delà
au delà de la respiration naturelle donc
je sais accessible oui parce qu'il n'y a
pas besoin de grosses capacités
il faut évidemment pour se distinguer
après il nous sert une grosse forme
d'entraînement mais gelé tout un chacun
n'importe quel physique n'importe quelle
physionomie morphologie peu peu pratique
et l'apnée peut-être jusqu'à 10 mètres
après il ya aussi à travailler tout ce
qui est vivant profondeur et les
oreilles les paliers et la respiration
mais je pense que c'est accessible à
tous et bien déjà
c'est après merci pourquoi j'ai une amie
qui nagent qui n'a jamais au bout rond
de temps en temps est un joueur elle m'a
dit j'ai à versailles la piscine au bond
ce qui était moins de stress hydrique
est de france et donc elle m'a dit
qu'elle a vu arriver une séance
d'entraînement pour les apnéistes et que
d'un seul coup de l'ambiance dans le
dans la piscine et voilà ça et elle
s'est dit est un truc bizarre ça a
vraiment où tout est devenu très très
très zen les gravillons se faire des
bombes
donc c'est ce que j'ai dit c'est pour
cette raison que je dis que c'est
accessible à tout le monde et est
ensuite voilà à moi d aviez le
connaissant il m'a dit viens parce que
très rapidement tu pourrais passer le
cap des 3 4 minutes et donc c'est oui
moi aujourd'hui comme je le fais tout
seul dans la baignoire ou à la seconde
gênant je n'étais pas sur une autre
minute et minutes 30 mai mais voilà il
m'a dit très rapidement tu pourrais
atteindre 3 4 minutes et je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui va être super
agréable à vivre
donc non je pense que tout le monde peut
essayer et 6 quels que soient les moyens
que l'on a
ben on va être passée de 20 secondes à
une minute mais on va chacun pouvoir
dépasser et avec des petites techniques
qui sont faciles à acquérir et puis
ensuite pourquoi est ce que tout le
monde peut aussi accéder c'est que ben
il suffit d'un maillot de bain point fr
de l'apnée donc moi j'attends le retour
de ceux qui se diraient je vais pouvoir
assister un 3 4 minutes alors en apnée
statique
peut-être que faire des longueurs et
bien je pourrai enchaîner deux trois
longueurs et ça ce serait pareil c'est
quelque chose qui quand on est jeune au
début on est content de pouvoir faire
une largeur et c'est vrai que là c'est
dessous dit un pur et j'ai réussi quand
même à dépasser mes capacités
donc voila moi je pense que c'est ça qui
est ça qui est ça parce que on peut le
faire et on peut le faire pour
progresser et se sentir pour dresser
tout seul
jean-mi si vous êtes en apnée depuis
environ 2 3 minutes après que chanteuse
sort de certains recours
coffre oui oui on peut tenir
ils tiendront une dernière réaction
juste avant qu'on passe au sujet sûr il
ya le l'équipe de rugby du racing l'an
dernier qui a fait une une séance
d'apnée avec un professionnel ça s'est
bien passé pour pour justement de
travailler la respiration est là parce
que ça ça servait aussi au rugby donc ça
c'est beaucoup de sport et au mental
notamment
oui on va continuer à parler de mer et
d'océans notre dans notre page coup de
projecteur direction la route du rhum
éric bellion est toujours en course à
bord de sa goélette comme un seul homme
ce mercredi 5 décembre le jour de
l'enregistrement de cette émission il
est actuellement à 10e et se rapproche
de la guadeloupe le skipper devrait
arriver entre le 8 et le 9 décembre mais
pour lui l'essentiel est de prendre son
temps pour se retrouver personnellement
il enregistré cette vidéo à la semaine
dernière premier jour je me sens bien
bien emmenées dans le mois que les faits
vivre cette aventure différemment 2007
course avec un angle différent quitter
qui est le land de la décélération
et pouvez pas savoir comme je le sens
bien
hier j'ai fait un grand point avec moi
même sur le pont du bateau juste là
à l'avant
et j'ai bu
toutes les merveilles que j'irai devant
les yeux à bateaux magnifique la lune la
mer le vent qui pousse cet océan
incroyable n'accueille il fait donc
décidé de prendre son temps et d'aborder
la course sous un autre angle la
question sur ce thème comprenez vous sa
démarche
les sales gueules sèches chevalier nous
éviter les duels
un petit duel entre yale dujarrier
jean-jacques austin aux sélections ouest
je ne comprends pas le concept quand on
est dans une compétition
même si comme roberto n'a dit les
chances y participer mais malgré tout
les autres ça fait trois semaines qu'ils
sont qui s'occupe qui sont arrivés les
films sont tes trucs là il avait ainsi
la route du rhum
il a fait appel et grim m ouais je pense
qu'il ya des centaines de personnes qui
font le trip que lui et qui partent ils
prennent une goélette ils font le tour
du monde
pas besoin d'aller dans un d'abord c'est
sûr qu'il est plus suivie depuis
contrôler le port sicilien sécurité
c'est une catégorie un peu spécial
vertement les bateaux dans la rue durant
il a pris il a pris de rome
mais voilà non encore ça concept ça fait
2 fut très bien il peut le faire il part
du havre il arrive à la barre technique
très bien rentrés dans un schéma de
compétition courses etc et voir une
attitude comme ça le dérange puisqu'il
veut le pommeau sud il n'y a pas main
mais je vois pas le vois pas l'intérêt
de la chose il peut le faire si bien sûr
qu'il ya un intérêt
vous êtes un compétiteur je suis un
compétiteur je ne conçois pas de ne pas
être sur le podium quand je prends le
part à une compétition mais quand on
prend le jeu prendre un exemple tout
bête
le marathon de paris qui a lieu tous les
ans il ya un vainqueur et il ya 44 1999
personnes qui derrière ne gagneront pas
et sur les 44 milles il y en a plus de
40000 qui étaient là pour simplement
finir donc voilà la nuit et bien il fait
son marathon de paris la rue de
clairfayts en marche arrière parce que
le voyou notre côté quoi les mecs qui
donne le maximum et ce dernier fait son
marathon
il y fait seul il fait son effet son
iron man il le fait et voilà pour lui
l'objectif c'est d'être à l'arrivée
c'est de pas de casser le matériel c'est
de prendre son temps de pouvoir méditer
avec avec les dauphins et avec les avec
les poissons volants et ben voilà c'est
cesser une c'est une autre approche de
la philosophie notre philosophie
j'y ai goûté j'y ai goûté pendant secret
des philosophies à ce type de
philosophie j'ai goûté et et le problème
c'est que ça maintenu trois mois quand
même j'ai commencé le roller au début
j'avais dit c'est fini plus de
compétitions comme le vélo et qu'il
avait un bateau j'ai commencé voilà avec
l'objectif de vauguières je veux faire
je veux faire une 45 une 45 au marathon
et au final des meilleurs chronos sont
entre une 5 et 10 et voilà il n'y a pas
de saison je pense qu'on a
marathon voilà et on n'a pas le même
enfin ouais on est on est pas juste
connectés de la même manière et donc lui
ben voilà il vit son truc et sur la
philosophie c'est de ces contre le tout
trop vite ça c'est gros c'est pour ça
qu'il qu'ils courent ces courses et pour
prendre le temps la maladie le fait que
s'accélérer ça on peut le comprendre
après je pense qu'ils ont ils ennuient
il ennuie personnes sur sa goélette à
finir la route du rhum il a peut-être
pris la place d'autres peut-être mais en
tout cas c'est c'est louable c'est
louable même si même si c'est pas
forcément le théâtre qu'il faut pour
exprimer ce type de ce type de
philosophie mais en tout cas ça nous ont
fait faux bond à la dernière édition du
vendée globe donc il avait terminé
d'ailleurs cette édition du vendée globe
capacités de vente performant qui s'y
connaît c'est important d'aller un peu
plus loin que mes voeux vous savez c'est
un message qui peut être odile et 10e
dans sa catégorie s'est pas dopé c'est
pas non plus ridicule dans sa catégorie
2 dixièmes donc ça veut dire qu'il y est
mais qui sont encore derrière lui et qui
eux étaient pas parties en disant je
veux faire tranquille dans la catégorie
et si on passait reçus au départ ici
qu'est ce que vous en pensez à vous a
pas attendu sur les routes jan pourtant
ce que je sais faire et moi même non
mais c'est bien il a lu ce collier
plusieurs fois
en fait en dépit de courson la ville a
pris le meilleur dans la villa parce que
là il est bien
j'ai pas trop brillé version là il est
temps qu'il arrive il devrait arriver ce
week-end s'il va parvenir
bon il ya d'ailleurs un film qui va
sortir son aventure lors du dernier
vendée globe justement 2016 a wave
action passe à la baisse est parfait non
mais oui j'aimerais bien le voir a
interviewé quelques il va mettre les
pieds sur la terre on pas ce matin avant
une dernière page la rubrique des bas
dans cette page débat nous allons parler
automobile tristan couëdel originaire de
ben la rue dans les yvelines va
participer du 30 décembre 13 janvier à
l'africa eco reis un rallye automobile
qui reliera monaco sénégal en passant
par le maroc et la mauritanie sur le
tracé de l'ancien dakar on écoute ce
passionné l'été sur notre plateau alors
historiquement avec mon associé on a un
rêve fou que l'on poursuit depuis
maintenant quatre ans et de réussir être
à l'arrivée du dakar celui qui se
déroule en amérique du sud
on avait tout imaginé pour repartir
cette aventure et puis le fait que la
course c'est un contexte un peu
particulier puisque le traversera qu'un
seul pays cette année ça restera au
pérou du coup on avait un rêve secret
avec mon associé c'est de toute façon un
jour ou l'autre de retourner en afrique
est donc là on a décidé d'anticiper ce
retour est de faire comme l'africa eco
race la question sur ce thème at il
raison de privilégier cette course
plutôt que le dakar oui ou non
oui oui jean alesi
lancez-vous dans un duel vous commencez
spécialiste automobile rallye moi je dis
non parce que il le dakar reste le dakar
et au niveau médiatique
y'a pas photo moi c'est la première fois
que j'entends le nom de la course alors
on peut expliquer que c'est le cours
existe quand même depuis 2009
mais voilà donc c'est encore pire je
croyais qu'elle était nouvelle c'est
pire parce que je pensais qu'elle était
toute récente de serre existe depuis
2009 ça veut dire qu'on n'a jamais
entendu parler quoi alors que le da
vinci
sauf que le dakar baldaquin d'en parler
et quand c'est le dakar tous les jours
car des trophées renault + non mais je
suis d'accord mais je suis d'accord
après après les shows politiques et les
choisit les sept duels ne ferait pas
comprendre les choix politiques et
sportifs
simplement je dis allez sur une course
comme celle là
à la place du dakar alors tenez parce
que ça coûte certainement beaucoup moins
cher déjà premièrement certainement mais
le dakar est sur le dakar c'est 38 1400
euros l'inscription allah n'est pas
seulement ce n'est pas ne sais pas mais
voilà foyer envoyé loïc meyer éric
bellion bellion rébellion oui ça peut
tous loïc les marais et donc c'est pour
ça parce que pour moi mais pour moi le
dakar est sur le dakar adoption s'il
veut vraiment avoir une course de
prestige pour moi c'est le dakar
donc c'est bien cette course est qu'ils
y aillent et qu'ils s'amusent auto qui
s'amusent après c'est un choix personnel
pour lui il l'a dit lui-même il voulait
revenir là bas on appris en afrique donc
c'est mais après je ne parle pas je ne
rentrent pas dans les considérations que
dakar a souffert au pérou ce qui a
longtemps gle dakar n'est plus le dakar
le dakar donc on parle pas de cette
course on parle de l'autre et dans ce
sens là et qu'ils se fassent plaisir et
ça reste quand même une compétition
automobile et ça reste quand même un
rallye automobile de prestige et vient
de jarrier ouais ben moi j'ai toujours
je rêvais de participer à au paris dakar
je vais pas dire dakar au paris dakar
c'est dans les villages 1000 euros sur
vous non parce que j'étais trop jeune et
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose que
j'aurais aimé trois buts c'est un truc
que j'aurais aimé aimé pouvoir faire
oui oui je sais mais bon j'ai pas fini
de vivre encore une race à part un peu
de temps donc pourquoi pas mais voilà
depuis que je trouve que ça a tout perdu
depuis qu'ils sont partis en amérique du
sud
c'est vraiment dommage et en effet ce
rallye africa africa re est cela qui a
pris la suite la suite du rallye du
paris dakar
devrait avoir une d'autres d'autres
lettres de noblesse et on devrait en
parler beaucoup plus parce que parce
qu'elles gardent l'esprit et elle
démontre que c'est toujours possible de
pouvoir
jean louis schlesser notamment qui a
créé cette africa ricort extrême et donc
du coup sa flotte
bien sûr qu'il ya gagné qui gagne 2
victoires et donc ça démontre que c'est
toujours possible d'aller d'aller courir
et d'aller faire des courses de
automobile sur le continent africain
donc donc voilà je comprends pas
pourquoi pourquoi à etsaut continue
d'aller sur sur le continent superficie
de sécurité c'est oui mais voilà
pourquoi certains arrivent à faire le
rallye aïcha des gazelles se fait aussi
sur le continent le continent africain
il ya toujours des courses sur le compte
twitter que son maroc par contre pour le
jeu c'est bien mais c'est le rallye
dakar a été jusqu'en égypte mariah carey
a été jusque jusqu'en afrique du sud
donc voilà c'est quelque chose qui est
qui est possible oui bien sûr que par
son aura et par sa médiatisation
il faisait aussi ap enfin les
terroristes voulaient parfois intervenir
et bloquer la course ça arrive et il ya
eu délit d'aidé des soucis mais
aujourd'hui voilà avec un peu mobilisés
mais avec un peu moins de médiatisation
et des courses qui arrivent à vivre sur
le continent africain
je trouve que c'est quand même dommage
pour pour c'est pour ce pour ces pays de
ne plus recevoir d'une cure recevoir
leurs alliés du le paris dakar
on sait que c'était une
une instabilité politique et des données
sécuritaires qui ont fait que le
paris-dakar devenu dakar a changé de
continent
mais quand on revoit les images et on
l'a aussi on a tous été bercé par ça
pour parler des époques grand bleu pour
l'apnée mais là on a été bercé par des
images d'afrique et la course de rallye
raid et notamment le paris dakar et le
dagar devrait rester notamment notamment
sur l'afrique
le rallye raid c'est en afrique mais
prix là même la même dans ces deux
dimensions que le paris dakar c'est
c'était des images maniement je recevrai
sur la bonne ligne et moi paris dakar
cet arrêté en 2019
en 2009 déjà il y avait ces pilotes
professionnels il y avait sept vedettes
ou de ces petites starlettes qui
prenaient le départ puis avaient tous
quand un genre de bricoleur versailles à
validé nous il ya du départ de ouf et il
y avait toute cette ribambelle de
au dessus des couleurs qui partait avec
les trois boulots et deux roues et face
c'était ça là je me retrouve pas du tout
ce dakar fidak arbon ça jamais tourner
l'amérique du sud leur temps il ya quand
même encore six cent mille spectateurs
qui ont regardé les aventures d'une à 44
4 0 et puis il faut dire qu'il y avait à
france télévisions qui a peut-être
antenne de l époque qui retransmettait
les avaient droit c'est la fin de cette
émission se retrouve le 19 décembre
prochain pour une nouvelle émission ou à
terminer par une citation d'hervé
loconte ans un pilote moto sur le
paris-dakar la douleur du paris dakar ce
n'est pas quand hui y est c'est quand tu
ne peux pas y retourner
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phase à
bientôt sur tv 70
[Musique]